hello everyone today we are going to
present on our research project which is
effects of microgravity on human induced
filaments simpsons cardiomyocytes
and we decided to check the effects of
microgravity on human cardiac and muscle
activity
so effects of microgravity
the effects of microgravity can be used
to explain the improvement on the
biological effects of radiation under
the weightlessness condition
microgravity is the most important
influence on the human organism in space
and long-term exposure of space flight
undergoes
uh dramatic changes on human body and
results in cellular oyster processes and
muscle entropy
as well as neurological disorders
microgravity induces many changes in
specialized cells and stem cells and it
also helps in understanding and
suppressing tumor metastasis
or tissue engineering where it induces
the scaffold free formation of
three-dimensional multicellular steroids
so we also
gathered this factorial representation
from canadian space agency
which shows like how does space affect
the human body
and as you can see
it affects whole human body starting
from brain
then hearts and blood vessels muscles
and nervous system bones
and it also damages the cataracts in the
eye and
damage
the dna which increases the risk of
cancer
pluripotent stem cells
human peripheral stem cells including
embryonic stem cells and induced
peripheral stem cells have the
capability to self immune indefinitely
and to differentiate into derivatives of
three generals that are equitable with
your dominant endoderm
induced peripheral stem cells are an
exciting tool that offer the potential
to advance the current state of the art
as they have derived from somatic cells
enabling the development of personalized
medical strategies and patient-specific
disease models
induced nutrient stem cells can be
differentiated into cardiac myocytes can
form patches is an eliminated cardiac
tissue and can and graft the damage out
and the first induced preparing stem
cell was generated by reprogramming skin
cells in the year 2006.
some of the studies found that induced
peripheral stem cells cardiomyocytes can
couple efficiently
damaged heart and restore the cardiac
contractility almost all found that
induced pre-protein stencil
cardiomyocyte transplantation is
arizogenic which is it causes
waiting irregularities in heart thus
having the use of induced people in stem
cell cardiomyocytes for cardiac
regeneration
about our data set this is the geu
session number
title effects of space flight on human
induced peripheral stem cell they like
cardiomyocyte structure and function
about these study authors did
so
exposure to microgravity was
given to the stem cells and they mostly
studied on the
uh
calcium handling of human industry brain
stem cell cardiomyocyte and
mitochondrial metabolism
authors decided to perform the same
study as previously done on mouse or rat
they generally focused on studying the
calcium handling effect and the heart
contracting prevent after the research
they concluded that they didn't observe
a great difference neither in calcium
handling or capacity not in the heart
contractility so they suggested that
microgravity affects mainly the
mitochondrial metabolism and the study
can be used for further research
so this is the pictorial representation
of gu dataset page and sample
characteristics so the whole treatment
and study was done for 4.5 weeks under
under the
microgravity exposure and after the
exposure
the cells were kept for one week of risk
so the whole study was done on the basis
of 5.5 weeks in total
so we had total number of 18 samples
six each in in in flight condition post
recognition and ground control so we
also created two different groups based
on our samples that is inside versus
ground and two straight versus ground
as the
data on geo was normalized we collected
the raw fight from sra and then
accordingly pipeline was
run so we first ran the rna-seq pipeline
called the quantile normalization pca
desective and enrichment analysis
so about the quantile normalization
quantity normalization is a technique of
mapping original values to the
corresponding quantile of a standard
distribution
and
it gives the values to the data where
null values are given
after round and seek analysis and we
also treat the pca under this pipeline
about the desective analysis
we have taken the parameters for d6 to
our like
for log fc threshold minus one and we
adjusted values that showed us 0.05 as
well as for gse analysis parameters uh p
value session was 0.1
and you also did the enrichment analysis
and gac analysis in this pipeline
now i would like to
[Music]
ask shivon to continue from here
thank you sv
as we can see from the image that after
the deceptive analysis we have found the
keg enriched pathways and geo gsa
enriched pathways
which were performed
by performing which are performed after
the enrichment analysis along with the
gsea analysis
these are the heat map results of ground
versus flight normalized data and ground
versus posted normalized data
from this plot the regulation of genes
can clearly be observed for each sample
that is ground and slight in both ground
versus flight flight and ground versus
post flight conditions
pca
it is an
unsupervised machine learning algorithm
used for dimension reducibility and
information compression
in our result we can see that the sample
to sample variation is dominating the
pca
sample 2 and sample five in both slight
and posted condition
are clustering together irrespective of
ground flight and post light
the segregation of data is more
pronounced in ground versus flight and
as compared to grand versus post flight
condition
[Applause]
as it is clearly visible from the bar
plot that the total
enriched pathways for ground versus
flight and ground versus post flight for
both gac and keg
a great variation is observed in grand
versus postcard condition the enrichment
of pathway was across the double as
compared to grand versus flight
condition
hence there were a lot of differentially
expressed genes and their statistical
filtering was
not giving the proper result
the data obtained from this pathway was
statistically relevant
but biologically irrelevant therefore
manual identification was made to filter
the pathway for further analysis
because a project was project revolves
around the effect of microscope
microgravity stress
on cardiac and muscle cell we have
confined ourselves in filtering the
pathway
manually related only to cardiac muscle
cells and stem cells
similarly a great variation was observed
in the cardiac related pathways
and in the muscle related pathways of
both gsa and keg
pathways
after filtering out the pathways
we have sorted on the basis of the set
size e score p value and p adjusted
values
from this we have analyzed that first of
all authors didn't focus authors focused
on a very few pathway related to the
study that is calcium activity on heart
contractility
they didn't focus on the other pathways
which are important to the
heart cardiac related
they also didn't consider overall effect
of microgravity and also the stress was
not observed
from our analysis we have found two
unique pathways first is pathway related
to pure potency of stem cells inside
condition
and second
muscle related pathway in postpartum
conditions
so as children just told that we have
founded two unique pathways out of those
two one is signaling pathway regulating
to the potential stem cells so this
pathway was found in the flight
condition and it was suppressed in the
post right condition
so
what are signaling pathways regulating
to the potential of stem cells
the
fluid potency of
stem cells is regulated and maintained
by transcriptional networks that include
a series of pluripotent transcription
factors
these predictive genes stimulate or
inhibit the expression of downstream
genes including the occurrence of some
signaling pathways and regulating the
fluid potency of stem cells the function
of signaling pathways regulating to
reproduce your stem cells retain the
potential of cell renewal and
multi-directional differentiation in the
action of signaling pathways regulating
the pure potency of stem cells so
having a better understanding of the
mechanism of these pathways could help
scientists study gene function and
disease
pathogenesis and promote the development
of regenerative medicine so as you can
see from the this genetic result
the top the
highly activated diseases from this
pathway are abreunel carcinoma and
summer carcinoma
apart from that we got 25 genes
activated in this pathway out of which
the top five genes are
oxb1 fgfr4 and one
sx1 fgfr3 followed by nuance others
[Applause]
now the another unique pathway which was
related to muscle was the
vascular smooth muscle contraction
pathway
it is it was observed in the posterior
condition due to the stress which was
observed in the microgravity condition
this
pathway is
responsible for hypotension
hypertensive disease and
we can observe c from the disgenet
result and out
and out of the 25 genes which were
present in this pathway highly expressed
genes are
adc 6 adc 5 and generally it is
6 5 4
and other pathways or and other genes
are highly also responsible
this is the
whole overall path pictorial
representation of the pathway of
vascular smooth muscle contraction
pathway from this we can see the genes
responsible and they're functioning in
the human body
this is the calcium dependent regulation
of the vascular smooth muscle
contraction which was not observed by
the authors
generally vascular smooth muscle
contraction pathway is slow and
whereas cardiac muscle undergoes a fast
and relative short cycle
contraction
both the cardiomyocytes and the vascular
contraction are dependent on the
hydrolysis of atp
function of this pathway is to
redistribute blood where oxygen
consumption is temporarily increased
excessive vessel contraction causes
hypertension and excessive
metabolization leads to the
hypotension
in the conclusion
we want to say that the pathways and
risks are statistically relevant but not
biologically relevant
the cardiac pathways are not
significantly changed in terms of flight
and post-flight condition
due to stress change in muscle
contraction was observed and after one
week of stress cells didn't get
recovered they require more resting
period
in grant buses flight and front versus
post right and which pathways were
getting doubled in both and gs analysis
we have also explained the two unique
pathways which were observed in our
research and was not observed by the
authors
these were the unique findings from our
research
which was totally outlet by the authors
in the last we want to say that our
research can be used for further study
of effect of microgravity stress on a
broad perspective for cardiac and muscle
cell and for study of diseases related
to stress observed
thank you thank you